he is the national columnist is that
that's that like is that like the ohio
state university the national columnist
for yahoo sports he is dan wetzel back
here in the rich housing show how are
you dan
that's right get it right the national
columnist for yahoo sports uh all right
let me just throw it right out to you
wha what's what's the a lot his i know
the alliance is historic i saw the the
graphic that came with the press release
um on on tuesday what what in the world
what what is this about dan wetzel
if you want to know why it's not uh you
shouldn't take it too serious
it's because the three logos of the
leagues there was no corporate sponsor
historic alliance brought to you by
for all the tostitos baby
alliance the fedex alliance like the
fact college sports didn't slap a
sponsor on that tells you this is just
nothing they're all at those titles baby
they didn't make a buck on it uh there's
no side contract now look it's uh
yeah i mean it's it's it's these leagues
trying to say
we still matter uh which they do um that
it's a full full push back on the sec
and saying we're gonna align and make
sure you don't run us over
and hopefully you don't take any more of
our teams um
and
their number one goal
is to make sure that when the bidding
for the college football playoff comes
out in whether it's two years or five
uh unfortunately they delay this thing
that it is not the sole
property of espn that espn doesn't get
to broadcast all of the college football
players they want
fox to be involved they want someone
else to be involved the way the nfl
playoffs are shown on all the networks
and that's because the sec and espn are
now exclusively together espn is
exclusive broadcaster of
the sec
the big ten the pac-12 particularly want
fox to be able to profit off the big
time games that the college football
playoff will create
and then have that kind of profit to
later put back into their contract deal
so that's the number one tangible goal
of this is to hit the brakes on the
playoff and make sure instead of it
going exclusively to espn that you have
multiple bidders um everything else is a
little bit nebulous
uh
possibly the scheduling alliance could
be a big deal in like 10 years
but
that's the number one first start thing
is don't let espn get all the money and
then keep giving it all to the sec
because the the way that
the way this is going dan is is creating
your own league creating your own super
league creating your own ncaa with mark
amert basically kneecapped by brett
kavanaugh at the supreme court level
and covid wiping out so many budgets
across
um collegiate sports that there's a gold
rush on trying to find out where you can
get the money back and how you can grow
your pot
certainly to continue on uh
you know try and operate in the black
and and pay for title ix sports and
things like nature i mean this is this
is what is happening right now
and you're saying that that the big ten
pac-12 and acc totally understand they
don't want the sec picking off more
people but are you saying that they
believe that espn is like a stalking
horse
um a television stalking horse
to be a partner for this new ncaa that
is being formed in the southeast part of
the united states is that what you're
saying yeah
some of them some of the more conspiracy
minded ones might think that or be
suspicious of that they all also do
business with the with espn now right um
i think it's more that
look
the the money the money in college
sports
is is obviously in tv
you have and as big as the ncaa
basketball tournament is this college
football playoff will dwarf that and
money but in college football you only
get so many games a year to get the big
big number the 10 million plus the 8
million plus
and like during the during a normal
season you might have one regular season
game get over 10 million viewers maybe
two ohio state michigan almost always
does
the sec championship game you know when
lsu is playing alabama or last year
there was a clemson notre dame game at
south bend saturday night they got but
those games are rare
but when the playoff comes and all of a
sudden you have
uh seven games that will do that kind of
number you've now created
you know
twice as many
uh really three times as many at that
point if you're counting on two or three
big games you now have 10
you don't want espn having all of that
and then being focused on what do we do
with with with the sec you have to have
fox have some money because as these
contracts go on so it's kind of a long
play it's also better for the sport to
be on more networks the nfl does it
right the nfl doesn't just get bigger
uh
ratings in college football it also gets
more dollars per eyeball
than
than them and they have all four
networks fighting against each other to
try to promote the sport they get it all
over the place so to move it around
makes a lot of sense they just don't
want espn to have so much power over the
sport because if you control
the college football playoff you are now
you have almost all of the big time
television events in college sports um
well we'll see what happens with cbs and
the and the basketball tournament that's
just a secondary kind of side thing so
they want that spread out and this is a
way of saying where to pump the brakes
now that's disappointing for fans who
are like hey we got to go through two
more seats before do we now have to go
through five i mean it's kind of like
you pulled the rug out from under us but
that's the primary goal
uh and so it's not
you know i don't i don't think it's fair
to say espn is just trying to wipe these
other guys out because they need the
other teams too
uh the sec is a big deal but it'll never
get the
national attention
the national rating unless everyone's
involved we've seen that when it's when
it's sec teams in the championship game
the ratings are lower you need a midwest
presence or a west coast presence or
something like that to get the the
bigger areas of the country to uh keep
you in i love this real talk right here
with dan wetzel national columnist of
yahoo sports because let's let's keep
talking real here dan because you know
eventually everyone's going to come
together i mean let's be honest that
this is leverage to make sure that
whatever final deal finally gets
together
um for these power five conferences or
power four if the big 12 is now left
picking up pieces and is not even part
of this
um that that this is all leverage for
for down the road as for for right now
was there a danger of clemson and ohio
state peeling off and joining
the sec along with oklahoma
and texas was there was that part of
maybe this conversation that got the acc
and the big 12 of the the pac-12 and the
big ten together have you heard anything
like that at all
there there wasn't any but if you look
at the
at the game pieces and you look ahead
you could see where there there might be
not necessarily with ohio state um the
big ten is really solid and ohio state
and you know to say ohio state michigan
joined
the sec makes uh just wouldn't make
sense institutionally for those schools
uh football is a big deal but the big
ten has a 10 billion dollar a year
um
uh
joint fund to do research and scientific
development and all of that and i know
we can all roll our eyes about the
academics but that matters on these
campuses it's talking 10 billion
so
and and if you're ohio state which done
a tremendous job improving its academics
the last 20 years you you're you're
recruiting your student body from
chicago and from pennsylvania and
michigan like to just go play in the
south would make a lot of sense they're
not going to give up everything for
football and michigan certainly not
going to do it so those things matter
more on the campus a 100 million dollar
football team is a big deal but it's not
as big as a 10 billion dollar having
access to 10 billion dollars in you know
driverless car funding and things like
that they're working on these schools so
all of that goes on
now if but if you look at the long term
and you say clemson and florida state
right
geographically culturally uh
academically um competitively
financially it makes a ton of sense for
those two to join the sec right they're
right in they're already practically
they're right there
it's not a big it's a much easier move
for clemson and florida state than it
would be for oklahoma and texas now
there's again there was no movement on
clemson and florida state right now but
if you're the big ten let's say you're
the big ten and you're looking because
people are like why is the big ken doing
this they really they're as strong as
the sec their tv money is just as big
they may not win the championship but
their programs are strong they're
getting there's a whole bunch of hundred
thousand seat stadiums that get filled
every week they're fine
why would you kind of lend your strength
to prop up these other leagues it's
because they want clemson you know they
want clemson and florida state to be to
feel good and if you're in that big ten
you're looking to say well i could see
these two jumping why don't we try to
help out the acc a little bit and make
it worth their while to stay because the
one thing clemson and florida state have
this is what club is what oklahoma and
texas gave up and they may regret it
forever because nebraska sure does
when you go to a harder league you can't
just roll out of bed but we're going to
ten and two at least this year
uh if we've got our program together or
work we've got an inside track on the
playoffs you now have to fight through a
much tougher league and so there's still
a lot of reasons for clemson and florida
state to stay right where they are
but
certainly you could look at that and go
boy that's not that's not some seismic
move if you said hey i'm going to join
this league the leagues already are in
your footprint dan wetzel here on the
rich eisen show my oldest son dan is
getting bar mitzvahed this very weekend
congratulations thank you sir let's
flash forward to when he gets out of
college
what does this scene look like
what does it look like when he gets out
of control yeah everything what does the
landscape look like
do you think crystal ball you have four
major conferences okay um look if this
deal goes forward and they haven't
worked out all the scheduling but the
plan they have for scheduling that
they're trying to figure out is to have
each school play
if you're in if you're north carolina
you will also play one team for the big
ten one team in the pac-12 every year if
you're michigan you play an acc and a
pac-12 team every year and you drop you
would basically now start playing 10
conference games and that's what you
would do
um
so
if that it takes a long time to get to
that because they've been schedules
planned out five six years in advance
and no one wants to break contracts and
and all of that but i would say if this
thing holds and it and it could it's
because that's a good scheduling deal
for
these these leagues
you'd be playing more high quality games
which i think fans would actually like
about 10 games a year
the sec would probably have to play 10
games amongst them itself
because they would be starved out of a
lot of non-conference games other than
the real rivalry games that would would
stay
georgia tech georgia florida state
florida louisville and kentucky and uh
um
clemson and south carolina the other the
you know and alabama would say well who
are we going to play the big ten won't
play us the pac-12 won't play at the ecc
won't play it you guys got notre dame
and you know a couple others so they
might have to go to 10 teams i actually
think you'll have more good games more
big television games and all of that but
you'll basically have four leagues uh
the big 12 teams will step back some and
and be that upstart uh the remaining big
12 uh big
big 12 teams and i think you'll have a
12 team playoff so it's it's it's not
like they're gonna this is gonna
significantly alter
what's going on they're just trying
whatever they can and uh now here's the
other part this is a handshake agreement
uh
in college sports mind you college
sports if your son let's put this away
if your son becomes a cross-country
runner yes sir that could go to the
local local college
they will make him sign a binding letter
of intent because they do not trust him
to leave them right they will have all
sorts of documents you have to sign if
you're the lowest athlete at the entire
athletic department yet we're to believe
that 41 schools just they're going to
work this together as a gentleman's
agreement so this is more likely blows
up than not
but if it goes
i mean
there are a whole lot of options for
these leagues and and so i think you'll
have a four league four major leagues 12
team playoff it it'll be fine no matter
how much they mismanage this thing
college football and to a lesser degree
college basketball is so good it can't
be screwed up see here's what i think it
is dan and you tell me if how far off i
am you could rate it on one to ten about
how how how
how accurate this might actually be
i think greg sankey who's been on this
show a couple times the sec commissioner
is a really smart fella
i think he
i think he is really smart really savvy
and terrific at his job
i think he sees what's going on with
mark emmert i think he sees what's going
on with the nil name image and likeness
i think he sees what's going on with the
supreme court the writing is on the wall
it is in neon letters
that it's open for business
oklahoma and texas is now in greg
sankey's fold
he is trying to maybe with as we pointed
out at the beginning of this
conversation with my former place of
business the worldwide leader in sports
ready to roll with an idea that he winds
up running the entire athletic world
and that everybody gets together at some
point certainly if the leverage that you
just said that this historic alliance
might have by saying okay enjoy i know
it just means more to y'all down there
in the southeast part of the united
states and the gulf south but guess what
enjoy keep playing each other that whole
usc alabama kickoff and jerry world see
ya that ain't happening so at some point
there might be some leverage point from
the historic alliance and everyone comes
together and not only do they have a
huge consortium of schools and academia
um that sankey's in charge of and that
espn essentially mostly televises but on
top of it they've got themselves an ncaa
basketball tournament to run and turn
the current bracket into the nit and
they run the entire world collegiately
that's the way i'm sort of seeing this
maybe i'm jaded
but this is the way i'm viewing it dan
your thoughts well they would need
all the leagues to come together because
they can't get the tv number they need
yes especially if college football fans
elsewhere take a
a um
opposition stance we know how our
country is now everything everyone's uh
it's not just rooting for your team it's
hating the other team and and people
don't watch the sec out of some kind of
pride and those are your hardest core
fans the most reliable tv viewers
so they have to and they just don't have
the population centers as much as
they've expanded to texas
you know and and you know in the
northeast the you know it's still
fledgling ratings you know in the
northeast led screen ratings out in
california well you still need those to
have big big numbers yes the problem
with the basketball tournament is very
profitable
but that basketball tournament
succeeds because it's a brilliantly set
up
it's the construct is perfect the first
weekend is about the upset yes it is and
the cinderellas that's what draws people
in you could still have them it's what
i'm saying you could still have them you
know like the the well you know they'll
take any scrap you get yes they'll still
have them they'll take any abilene
christian will show up if you invite
them yeah um and you have to have that
you know can you replace the ncaa you
you can but you kind of at this point
the ncaa is completely neutered that's
what i'm saying sankey's got sankey sees
a void he sees a void and and and and
you know it's it's going to take some
time but there's there's a a world to
dominate and the first dominoes were
were texas and oklahoma
so that's the way i'm kind of viewing it
and the ncaa is fairly harmless at this
point they don't really take much money
from anybody they give it all back to
the schools
and
you still need someone to run the
tournament and you still need somebody
to
keep the trains running on time and with
name images like this there's no more
enforcement
because it's impossible to decipher
it would take it would take a thousand
forensic
accountants to figure out whether a
booster actually gave money
because he wanted you know i mean just
the money's there so
there really isn't a whole lot the ncaa
is going to do in the future that's
going to anger anybody
you almost you would you know it's it's
really just
it's not even that big of a building in
indianapolis there's a few hundred
people working and they're doing
a lot of what they do is is very well
done right the basketball tournaments
generally run well but you gotta have
somebody running your field hockey
tournament all those things
so i'm always skeptical of replacing the
ncaa because it's like you have to then
create another ncaa at this point the
ncaa has almost no no power you're
sharing scraps with division three
schools and things like that
this is oh this is why i'm saying so
much in this consolidates power and greg
sankey is playing chess and they're all
looking long-term that's why everyone
was like well this announcement is
stupid and nothing changed today it's
like yeah that's not what this is about
it's a long-term plan to try to support
the other long-term plan but nobody's
quite sure what their plans are so my my
theory is more closer to possible rather
than tin foil hat
right it also definitely possible oh 100
i just don't know how you do it
this time but there's no tinfoil hats
anymore man everything's every
anything's possible well tin foil hat
brought to you brought to you by
reynolds wrap there you go then i will
take a college i mean we just had a 40
we basically had a 41 team conference
get created there's only 32 teams in the
whole nfl
thanks i mean there are no no tinfoils
anymore everything's possible it's just
like where is this going to land i just
probably have yes no one is in charge of
this this sport nobody you go show up
and say who's in charge and they go they
point to 10 different guys well i would
say um
greg sankey's in charge that's the
probably in charge yeah what i'm saying
right now thanks for the call dan wetzel
um let's chat down the line during the
season enjoy your your time that you
have between now and kickoff thanks
thank you man appreciate it national
columnist of yahoo sports dan wetzel on
the rich eisen show
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here